i think when you look at the issue of  mixed messages it is  difficult at times to convey both hope  in the future  and the danger that is now and that is  what we're trying to do  and i i ca i will certainly agree that  we are trying to  walk and chew gum at the same time we  are trying to convey  to everybody in the region that we will  have  legal processes for people in the future  and we're standing those up as soon as  we can  but at the same time  you cannot come through irregular means  it's dangerous and you know the majority  of people will be sent  out of the united states because  that is the truth of it we want to be  honest with people  and so we are trying to send both  messages  and smugglers are only trying to send  one message  so we're relying on every means we can  to get that  message out there and that leads me to  want to  read